قال الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ان نشره
موسكو اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه في بيلاروسيا
امر غير مسؤول من جانبها بشان انضمام
اوكرانيا واشار الرئيس الامريكي في رده
على اسئله للصحفيين الى ان واشنطن لا تسهل
هذا الانضمام ما لم تلبي اوكرانيا
المعايير الخاصه بالحلف على غرار الدول
الاعضاء الاخرى وفيما يتعلق بالعلاقات مع
الصين اعرب بعيدا عن امله في اجراء لقاءات
مع الجانب الصيني خلال الاشهر المقبله
حول هذه التصريحات نذهب الى واشنطن ينضم
الينا من هناك مراسلنا محمد العلمي محمد
ما جديد هذه التصريحات وماذا بخصوص
توقيتها
ليست جديده حتى الرئيس جوبادر نفسه قال في
تصريحات مقتضبه سريعه للغايه وهو في طريقه
للطائره انه سبق له ان قال الكلمه نفسه في
مناسبات مختلفه لكن مختلفه هذه المره ان
روسيا اكدت بالفعل انها نقلت اسلحه نوويه
تكتيكيه الى روسيا البيضاء وليس الى
الحدود مع اوكرانيا
في اكتوبر الماضي كان الرئيس بيضا قد
عبر عن الاعتقاد بان موسكو في نظره انذاك
سترتكب ما وصفه بخطا جسيم ان ارتكبت
يعني استخدمت اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه في
اوكرانيا كان الحديث انذاك في ظل مزاعم
موسكو بان اوكرانيا تستعد لاستخدام قنبله
قذره في اوكرانيا لكن السؤال ماذا سيفعل
الرئيس بيضا مع كل هذه التحذيرات سواء
العام الماضي او هذا العام بعد ان تطورت
الامور الى نشر الاسلحه تكتيكيه فعلا في
روسيا البيضاء لكن لم تستخدم في اوكرانيا
احد مراكز التفكير هنا في واشنطن
على لسان احد مفكريه اقترح قبل بضعه ايام
فقط ان على البيت الابيض ان يمنح
الاوكرانيين اسلحه نوويه تكتيكيه في مقابل
استخدام موسكو لهذه الاسلحه ضد اوكرانيا
معللا ذلك بان الولايات المتحده ضمنه امنه
اوكرانيا في محادثات بودابس عام
1994 مقابل اخلائها من الاسلحه النوويه
انذاك ومنحها لروسيا وان الولايات المتحده
الان تتحمل مسؤوليه اخلاقيه لتوفير
الحمايه النوويه لاوكرانيا شكرا لك يا
مراسل نا محمد العلمي